給湯器）「熱いお湯が出ます」
ちょっとお風呂入りまーす
〈はーい
あああああああああああああああ
熱い
はいというわけで今
お風呂に入っております
はい、来てからだいたいもう5分
経っているんですけど
まぁなんせ僕ん家は今
人がたくさんいるんすよ
はじめアミューズメントパーク
人がたくさんいるんで
で僕は今、お風呂入って来ますつって
もう5分経っているんですけど
家主ってかあの僕が
あの家主の僕が
お風呂長いと
あの僕がいなくても
平気な顔されると
ちょっと僕さみしいんで
あの家に今
色んな人達がいるんですけど
僕がお風呂に入ってから
どれくらい経つと心配して
様子を見に来てくれるか
またはあのー、のぼせて
助けに来てくれるか
ちょっと検証したいと思います
なんでもうこの動画もう僕だと終われませんので
ってか湯けむりすごいな
やばい煙が
熱湯風呂に入っているから
湯けむりがやばすぎる
助けてくれるまで
僕はこの熱湯風呂から
出ることができないので
このまんま待とうと思います
では
これによってどれだけみんなは
僕のことを気にしてくれるのか
わかると思うんで
ちょっと待ちましょう
ってか湯けむりすごい
10分経ちました
まだね来る気配はありません
熱いです
助けてください（切実）
ふぅー
はぁー
ハァハァ
あの僕…
キツイ…
ぺちぺち　ぺちぺちぺち
ぺちどんどんぺちぺちどんどんどん
（リズミカルなぴちどん）
（だ、誰も来てくれない…）
ふううううううううううう
20分経ちました
今の所
誰一人
来てくれる気配はありません
ちょっと頑張ります
やばい…
喉…
お風呂が熱すぎて
頭ぶっ飛びそうです
あーーーーー
あーーーーーーーー
ああーーーーーーーー
やばい
手痺れてきた手痺れてきた
ハァハァ〜
やばい
やばいよ
ちょっと
水…水水水！
あの長風呂はいいんですけど
適度な水分は
必ずしましょう
♪トゥットゥー　トゥットゥー
ゴキゲンな蝶になって きらめく風に乗って
今すぐ キミに会いに行こう
余計な事なんて 忘れた方がマシさ
これ以上 シャレてる時間はない
＠；〜/（何が） WOW WOW〜
この空に届くのだろう
だけど WOW WOW〜
明日の予定もわからない
無限大な夢のあとの
何もない世の中じゃ
そうさ愛しい
想いも負けそうになるけど
Stayしがちなイメージだらけの
頼りない翼でも
〈まだですか？
上がります